i
[Música]
a
los jóvenes chinos esgrimen las mismas
razones que los occidentales las largas
jornadas laborales la carestía de vida o
la voluntad de disfrutar del tiempo
libre la tasa de fertilidad está en el
13 muy lejos del 21 necesario para
mantener la población a medio plazo no
funcionó el permiso para tener el
segundo hijo hace cinco años así que
pocos son optimistas de que vaya a
funcionar el permiso para tener el
tercero recientemente aprobado china
será el primer país en envejecer sin
haber conseguido el pleno desarrollo y
eso acarreará graves problemas
socioeconómicos se ha reducido ya la
masa laboral y se incluyen tensiones en
la caja de la seguridad social es por
eso que el gobierno aumentará la edad de
jubilación muy baja ahora 55 años para
mujeres y 60 para hombres es una medida
imprescindible pero que no se había
tomado hasta ahora por el miedo al
descontento social que genera
[Música]
a pesar de que se habló mucho de un
'baby boom' derivado de la pandemia ésta
terminó contribuyendo a tener un efecto
opuesto y la tasa de natalidad en eeuu
llegó a su punto más bajo en más de un
siglo la ansiedad por el cob y su
impacto en la economía hicieron que la
natalidad bajaron 4 por ciento en
comparación con el 2019 y que en
diciembre la reducción fuera de un 8%
comparado con el año anterior eeuu que
era uno de los países desarrollados con
una tasa de fertilidad que aseguraba el
reemplazo generacional ahora tiene menos
jóvenes que las personas que envejecen
hace 12 años cada mujer tenía un
promedio de 2,1 niños y hoy ese promedio
es de 16 niños en las mujeres asiático
americanas la tasa de natalidad bajó un
8% en hispanas bajo un 3% y en mujeres
afroamericanas y blancas bajo un 4%
[Música]
la tasa de natalidad en españa lleva
años descendiendo desde los años 80 pero
con la crisis del cobi 19 cayó a los
mínimos históricos de 1941 una caída del
23 por ciento en sólo un año cuando ya
españa en 2019 contaba con una de las
tasas de fecundidad más bajas del mundo
y estas cifras se explican pues porque
los jóvenes españoles están sumergidos
en una crisis económica casi el 40% de
pago juvenil la tasa más alta de la
unión europea cuando ya venían de otra
crisis en 2008 por lo que los jóvenes
tardan cada vez más
en emanciparse pero el principal
problema llega de aquí diez años cuando
los llamados y numerosos baby boomers se
jubilan pues con la poca cantidad de
jóvenes que actualmente están cotizando
el sistema de seguridad social no podrá
asumir no podrá pagar sus pensiones
españa con este déficit demográfico ve
amenazado su sistema de bienestar
[Música]